et pour en parler avec nous alexis
poulain éditorialistes rt france bonsoir
alexis poulain merci d'être avec nous à
la houppe air sénateurs et l'air de
côte-d'or merci de la côte d'or merci
d'être avec nous nos côtés également par
sky bruno m'égare ban chef du service
réanimation de l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris bonsoir à vaulruz nommé germann
merci d'être avec nous nouvelle date
butoir du 31 juillet 2022 pour le passé
ni terre ça se situe bien au-delà de
l'élection présidentielle ça ne nous
avait pas échapper certains opposants
d'ailleurs accuse emmanuel macron
d'enjamber le scrutin présidentiel vous
avez été d'ores et déjà nombreux à
réagir sur télégramme elle est pour se
mettre dans l'ambiance on va regarder un
petit message posté par david abus de
pouvoirs avec en arrière pensée de
mettre en place les identités numériques
pour mieux nous contrôler et le vente à
distance pour s'assurer de la réélection
du président sortant alors ça te
paraître peut-être complotistes quand on
voit ça comme ça mais c'est une idée qui
revient quand même souvent nous
contrôler et il faut en parler
crevons l abcès sur ce plateau
déjà alain houpert sur cette idée de
réassurer l' élection d' emmanuel macron
est ce que vous trouvez ça dénué de sens
où vous partager une partie du
diagnostic
je m'aperçois que maintenant on peut
dire c'était mieux avant c'est à dire
que on a restreint beaucoup de liberté
individuelle comme vous l'avez parler et
puis
[Musique]
je dirais pour paraphraser michel
audiard il ose tout
un gouvernement en gouvernant par la
peur on fait peur aux français
gabriel atallah a annoncé aujourd'hui la
prolongation du pass sanitaire
la prolongation il a dit carrément la
prolongation mais il ya quand même un b
à ba rang démocratie c'est de passer par
le parlement donc des effets d annonce
et qu'est ce que pensent et citoyens
français ben ils les regardent la
télévision mais il croit qu ils en
oublient complètement parlement et c'est
un manque de respect vis-à-vis du
parlement et ça illustre un petit peu ce
quinquennat le manque de respect et
l'arrogance
alexis foulard justement ce que nous dit
alain houpert ce contrôle du parlement
qui est évidemment nécessaire dans notre
fonctionnement de la démocratie c'est
peut-être cela qui rend gens justement
des malentendus de ce type on veut non
surveillée on veut nous contrôler il ya
ce gros malentendu alors c'est pas mal
entendu je crois qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui que ce gouvernement est
dangereux pour la démocratie il l'a
prouvé maintes fois que ce soit dans la
gestion calamiteuse de des
manifestations des gilet jaune avec une
violence d'état qui n'était jamais
atteinte jusqu'à présent au moins au
21ème siècle et puis là on le voit avec
cette façon de gérer cette crise en état
d'urgence sanitaire permanente
c'est-à-dire qu'on met entre parenthèses
la démocratie volontairement avec en
plus des contre-pouvoirs qui sont soit
méprisé soit qui s'allonge devant le
gouvernement le conseil d'état conseil
constitutionnel qui ne trouve rien à
redire de dire que finalement c'est
normal que le président décide de tout
seul en conseil de défense sous le sceau
du secret défense sans consulter les
représentants du peuple en ayant une
politique sanitaire qui n'a plus rien de
salutaire parce qu'il faut dire
aujourd'hui si le passé ni terre a une
raison d'être c'était est d'ailleurs
monsieur b garnham l'avait dit pour
vacciner les français c'est fait on a
atteint un taux de vaccination un des
plus forts d'europe pour ce qui est du
taux d'incidence il est le plus bas que
qu'on n'ait jamais connu ces derniers
mois et là on nous dit non c'est jamais
on pourrait avoir une flambée épidémique
et je me rappelle des médecins de
plateau qui nous disait en août que à la
rentrée avec l'ouverture des écoles on
aurait sans doute une forme et il n'y en
a pas eu donc pourquoi on continue avec
ce pass sanitaire pourquoi on a là des
amendes de cette soixante quinze mille
euros et des peines de prison de cinq
ans alors que monsieur benalla qui a
utilisé des passeports diplomatiques et
qui a menti devant une commission d
enquête parlementaire lui a eu 500 euros
damende on est où on n'est plus en
france clairement on n'est plus en
démocratie française on est plus en
république française la liberté elle
n'est plus la légalité elle n'est plus
là entre vacciner en vacciner ceux qui
n'ont pas ce qu'ils n'ont pas et la
fraternité n'en parlons pas puisque là
on demande aux français de se contrôler
les uns les autres et ça devrait devenir
quelque chose de normal non on doit
refuser cet état de fait on doit refuser
de vivre en état d'urgence permanent et
je trouve aujourd'hui que les
oppositions sont inexistantes très molle
ce pour ne pas dire volatile et ce
président qui se permet tout alors que
je suis désolé c'est pas ça la france
c'est pas ça la démocratie et cette
gestion sanitaire il faut le dire et le
redire elle n'a plus rien de sanitaires
preuve en est quand on voit les chiffres
ou alors dites le nous les vaccins ne
marche pas le pas salutaire ne marche
pas qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on
fasse de plus en valais poser la
question aux médecins à brno et megaman
brille méga vanins gabriela salle qui en
conseil des ministres disait tout
simplement aujourd'hui l'épidémie n'est
pas terminée nous a réservé des
surprises par le passé donc on se
protège sa serait imprudent de se
désarmer dit il votre avis vous de
docteur
écoutez je suis d'accord il faut être
encore prudentes pourquoi parce que le
virus n'a pas disparu il circule à un
niveau certes très bas aujourd'hui en
raison de l'application des mesures
barrières mais avec le refroidissement
des températures avec la reprise plus
intensive des activités en intérieur
par analogie à ce que l'on a connu les
hivers passés ils pourraient repartir à
la hausse d'ailleurs l'épidémie
aujourd'hui ne reste plus alors la plus
grande probabilité c'est que onze
puissent se retrouver sur un plateau un
plateau d'ailleurs d'où le niveau sera
dépendant
du respect pas des mesures barrières si
on veut un plateau plutôt bas comme
actuellement il faudra maintenir les
mesures barrières si on veut un plateau
plus haut comme au royaume-uni et bien à
ce moment là on pourra se passer des
mesures barrières je ne suis pas
convaincu qu'on va avoir un rebond
épidémique aussi important que l'hiver
précédent malgré tout ça reste qu'une
hypothèse et c'est pourquoi il vaut
mieux être encore prudent pour quelques
jours afin de voir dans quel sens
l'épidémie par c'est pourquoi pour moi
de mon côté je serais d'avis encore pour
maintenir le pass sanitaire jusqu'à la
fin de l'année après que le gouvernement
et envie d'avoir la possibilité de le
garder jusqu'à juillet ça se comprend
parce qu'évidemment on va rentrer dans
une période électorale où très
probablement les centres d'intérêt
seront détournés des aspects sanitaires
et à ce moment là ça serait dommage de
gâcher l'élection de gâcher la campagne
par un virus qui reprendrait avec à
nouveau des hôpitaux surchargés de
travail et des morts ou plus grand
nombre donc je crois que la prudence
s'impose aujourd'hui si effectivement il
ne se ne s'est rien passé d'ici la fin
de l'année eh bien on sera plus serein
pour peut-être retirer le pass annuel à
laon père vous êtes sénateur on l'a dit
vous êtes aussi médecin vous rejoignez
un petit peu la vie de votre confrère
j'entends les arguments dont confrères
bonhomie kerman mais il n'y a rien de
pire dans l'histoire que les trous de
mémoire et bruno même me garbade me fait
penser à ce journaliste qui en 1880
annonçait la mort de victor hugo qui est
mort cinq ans plus tard et quand victor
hugo est mort ce journaliste a dit nous
avions été les premiers à annoncer la
mort de victor hugo et c'est un peu ce
qu'il fait puisque le 12 juillet il
déclarait sur rmc que c'est en septembre
que l'on risque une montée des
hospitalisations quand nous serons tous
à l'intérieur or ça n'a pas été le cas
et puis pronostics il y en a eu plutôt
bien malin celui qui a su prédire ce
qu'il espère
on est un petit peu face à kas ambre qui
annonce des cartons qui est très
pessimiste il va y avoir une hécatombe à
la route à la toussaint il va y avoir
une et quatre tombes à noël et je
rappellerai des propos de monsieur
milliard man qui disait que les tests à
elle être payant pour obliger les gens à
se faire vacciner
est ce que c'est de la médecine ou est
ce que c'est de la politique moi je suis
médecin et je suis poli tique donc j'ai
le droit de m'interroger
sentiment de devoir une schizophrénie et
puis en plus
professeur été
surpris de la fulgurance du variant
delta
pourtant dès le mois de mars le
professeur comme disait que qui en
imitant infectiologues disait que la
nature est bien faite virus est
contagieux
- il est mortel et l 23 août sursis news
monsieur mega man
là on a atteint le summum de l'argument
inaudible puisqu'il a déclaré le variant
delta cherche les personnes non
immunisées jolie pour les infectés et
al'inverse dès qu'il voit une personne
qui a un système immunitaire qui le
reconnaît il dévisse sa route donc à
force d'être cassandre il va être
entendu un jour c'est directement
ce qui me fait peur c'est ce discours
qui est tenu et c'est sur ce discours
que l'exécutif se repose au fond ces
décisions politiques renault mégane la
réponse quand même puisque vous êtes
directement interpellé par nos amis
sénateurs alors bien sûr ce avec hérault
rajoute-il sur ce bateau
il n'empêche vous porter la voix de
nombreux français alain houpert de son
côté aussi est ce que le gouvernement
gouverne par la peur effectivement pour
forcer à la vaccination parce que c'est
ce qui arrive tu est payant le 15
octobre aujourd'hui pas sanitaire
prolonger tout est fait pour que les
français même récalcitrants haye enfin
faire la piqûre
alors tout d'abord je voulais remercier
monsieur le sénateur parce que à
l'évidence il le suit toutes mes
interventions et à collectionner une
anthologie de ce que j'ai dit alors j'ai
bien pas pour lui que malheureusement
tous mes propos sont exactes tout
d'abord effectivement il y à bien
aujourd'hui un arrêt du recul de
l'épidémie avec peut-être une ré
augmentation alors c'est vrai que et ça
je suis d'accord nous avions plutôt
pronostiquer une reprise de l'épidémie
vers la mi septembre mais nous ne sommes
que vers la mi octobre donc on va dire
avec le variant delta ii les choses sont
survenus un mois et demi avant ce que
l'on avait prévu donc l'erreur est
humaine un nouveau variant est arrivé
beaucoup plus contagieux et donc ce que
l'on attendait un mois et demi après est
arrivé un mois et demi avant
deuxième point je ne crois pas m'être
trompé en disant que le virus préfère
contaminer les personnes sans immunité
que celles ci soient naturelles ou
acquise après vaccination
désormais c'est clairement démontré que
lorsque l'on est immunisés naturellement
après vaccination on a bien sûr un
risque moindre d'être contaminés est
évidemment un risque bien moindre de
développer une forme grave voire
mortelle donc tout ça est tout à fait
vrai le virus préfère bien contaminé
infecter les personnes non immunisées
donc j'allais dire
nous sommes des médecins nous sommes
responsables nous devons tenir un
discours
protecteur de la population
le laxisme malheureusement ne paie pas
et peut engendrer des catastrophes
on a vu dans l'année passée
que le virus peut nous réserver des
surprises il vaut mieux être prudent
aujourd'hui le pass sanitaire est entré
dans les moeurs on va dire il n'empêche
pas une reprise quasi normal de la vie
sociale et économique pourquoi s'en
passer pourquoi le retirer aujourd'hui
pour le réintroduire en catastrophe
merci déjà mais monsieur dr
merci à vous deux la première chose se
passe sanitaire ne doit surtout pas
entrer dans les moeurs bien au contraire
ça voudrait dire que on quitte
clairement la démocratie libérale on est
en train d'entrer dans un régime où les
mouvements sont contrôlés ou l'autorité
d'aller dans un lieu ou un autre et
contrôler rappelez-vous les paroles du
président de la république disait jamais
le passé ni terre ne serait utilisé pour
les activités du quotidien maintenant on
en est à le passe à lithaire c'est juste
en juillet 2022 et ça passe normalement
comme si c'était normal non surtout pas
c'est s'habituer à ce genre de mesures
liberticides qui fait qu'on va quitter
les rives de la démocratie pour de bon
ses deux meilleures années dans son rôle
certain temps les scientifiques de
médecins alors comme dans un rôle mais
tu es plus davantage non servette alors
je parlais je vais poser une question de
médecins qui sont sur le plateau on sait
maintenant que l'immunité naturelle
fonctionne également contre le delta en
plus de limiter proférées par les
vaccins pourquoi dans le pass sanitaires
on ne prend pas en compte limiter
naturel alors qu'on peut tout à fait la
calculer aujourd'hui que des études
montrent que l'immunité naturelle
fonctionne donc c'est bien que se passe
il est passé ni terre s'il était
sanitaires on demanderait aux français
et particulièrement aux enfants de faire
un test pour savoir s'ils ont été soumis
au cabinet s'ils ont l'immunité
naturelle est ce que vous pouvez vous
médecin me donner la réponse 2 pourquoi
l'immunité naturelle n'est pas prise en
compte dans le passé mme terre
elle est tout à fait pris en compte dans
le passât ni terre puisque en fait les
personnes qui ont déjà fait la fiction
c'est moi qui gagne à cuisin se voudra
plus longtemps et sert positivo ou de
d'anticorps acquis de façon naturelle et
bien non droit qu'à une seule dose de
vaccination six mois plus tard donc on
tient bien compte du fait qu'une
personne a bien fait une infection
naturel et acquis une immunité naturelle
d'ailleurs les études semblent montrer
que lorsque l'on a fait une infection
symptomatique et que l'on a reçu une
voire deux doses supplémentaires de
vaccins eh bien on est dans la situation
la meilleure en termes de protection
contre le risque de faire une forme
grave de la maladie mais les six mois
n'ont rien de médical ils ont été mis là
tout simplement parce que je dis on
mettra six mois alain houpert a ouvert
il ya beaucoup de messages on les voit
parfois des filets sur la
constitutionnalité effectivement
puisqu'il ya aussi la question de l'état
d'urgence qui pourrait être dans ce
projet de loi qui pourrait être lui
aussi prolongé ce qui pose évidemment
une question de droit et pourtant
plusieurs fois d'ailleurs ce
message nous le dit le conseil d'état a
finalement validé l'action du
gouvernement ça veut dire quoi que le
conseil d'état et le conseil
constitutionnel sont à la solde de aussi
du gouvernement vous diriez ça où il ya
eu des mauvaises interprétations des
juges je dirais que le conseil d'état et
le conseil constitutionnel
est plus proche de ce gouvernement que
qu'il n'était
des précédents gouvernements où on avait
des qpc qui revenait positive et
maintenant ça sert plus à rien de faire
une qpc mais je voudrais revenir sur ce
passé ni terre il ya une rupture
d'égalité entre celui qui est vacciné
qui secoue pas faussement protégés et
qui se croient faussement
contaminants contam mineurs et le celui
qui est testée c'est ce que ce qu'on a
fait aujourd'hui nous avons un pass
vaccinale et nous avons été testé ça
prouve une chose que celui qui est testé
à moins de risque de contaminer les
autres que celui qui est vacciné qui se
croient faussement non contaminants donc
j'aimerais qu'on se pose vraiment une
question scientifique d'éthique médicale
sur qu'est ce qui importe c'est très
important puisque les tests vont être
payant donc on va avoir plus de vacciner
parce que les gens se sont vaccinés
pourquoi pour avoir la paix pour aller
au cinéma pour vivre ensemble ils se
sont pas vaccinés par plaisir et c'est
ce que n'a pas compris le gouvernement
et le président la république au nom qui
sent trop compris je suis un homme de
terrain j'entends ce qui se passe il y a
une haine
il ya
une semaine que je n'ai jamais ressenti
vis-à-vis de notre de notre classe
politique
qui a accepté ça et j'ai peur que
dans l'élection qui va se passer
on trie pas dans les urnes mais ce qui
va sortir des urnes ça va être très
surprendre très très sûr pendant donc
j'aimerais qu'on se pose la question
et puis qu'on
la vraie protection c'est le test et
qu'on continue à le faire gratuit parce
que si on veut vraiment aider les
français faut continuer à les tester
parce que le jour où tout le monde sera
vacciné on continuera à tester les 1 ça
sera payant sur veut une efficacité
réelle il faut que la preuve
antigénique que le patient que le que la
personne n'est pas contaminantes l ex
poulain il ya la critique des manuels la
tranche sur ce plateau mais enfin il ya
aussi ces sénateurs socialistes
socialistes ont parlé tout à l'heure on
imagine que vous avez voté contre alain
houpert
infligeant on va en parler qui prenait
donc la vaccination obligatoire donc
c'est pas l'apanage des gouvernements
mettront à l'est les socialistes eux
mêmes aujourd'hui rendre la vaccination
obligatoire on commence dès 12 ans mais
absolument vous avez dessinateur
aujourd'hui qui défendent cette
vaccination obligatoire dès 12 ans
sachant que les études de laboratoire
sont fait rappelons le sur très peu
d'enfants en réalité on a là
[Musique]
des preuves données par les labos mais
compte tenu du fait que les enfants sont
moins à risque que les autres alors ils
sont condamnés en mai ils ont sans doute
déjà eu si on vaccine les enfants alors
à ce moment là on fait forcément intro
d'un test de d'anticorps pour savoir
s'ils ont été exposés au virus ou non ce
serait la moindre des choses mais
pourquoi vouloir rendre ce vaccin
obligatoire quand déjà on a je ne sais
pas 70% de la population vaccinée ce qui
est un énorme et que maintenant on parle
de troisième dose en fait aujourd'hui on
a l'impression que le passé littéraire
est là pour pousser ceux qui ont deux
doses à voir la troisième parce que il y
en a certains qui ne souhaitent pas
avoir la troisième et donc on se dit bon
on va faire comme en israël le pass
annie terre c'est seulement six mois si
vous avez que deux doses et puis après
il y aura les mises à jour chaque année
sans doute puisque les labos sont partis
sur une base annuelle un peu comme le
vaccin de la grippe donc c'est quoi ces
impasses a été ravi qu'on nous propose
si on rentre dans ce jeu et c'est bien
pour ça que je suis absolument contre ce
principe de passes annie terre parce
qu'on est en train de changer de monde
et et de l'accepter et on ne peut pas
l'accepter quand on vient quand on a
grandi dans une démocratie libérale où
on peut se mouvoir alors y'a des
passeports et les frontières certes est
encore schengen a fait en sorte que ce
soit un peu flou mais là on se retrouve
à voir des passeports chez nous tout
simplement pour aller dans un lieu qui
est un lieu de vie c'est inacceptable
c'est inacceptable ce virus il est là
pour durer on est en train de faire une
politique sanitaire qui n'en est pas une
quête une politique de contrôle des
populations une politique même anti
insurrectionnelle quasiment et enjamber
la présidentielle avec ce pass
sanitaires bien sûr qu'on peut se poser
des questions alors certes vous allez me
dire c'est complotistes mais non ça
mérite de se poser de questions parce
que en parallèle le ministre de
l'intérieur nous parle de vote à
distance et non pas de vote par
correspondance mais de vote à distance
dont il faut savoir encore ce qu'il
entend par là
alain houpert oui mais aujourd'hui le
sénat a rejeté cette proposition des
socialistes et le gouvernement aussi la
rejeter bon j'ai peur que ce soit un
écran de fumée pour nous dire voilà on
n'a pas pu vacciner tout le monde
puisque le parlement
voulue et on va repousser le passé ni
terre donc moi je pense que ça serait
les gens n'en veulent plus de se passer
ni taire les gens on minimise ce qui se
passe dans les rues tous les samedis moi
je suis effaré quand je vois ce qui se
passe depuis ma fenêtre à des gens
puissent vous aussi vous êtes dijonnais
je fais un châssis
quand je vois la rue de la liberté
qu'elles ont complètement pleines de
monde et qu'on dit qu'il ya eu 800
personnes et dijon c'est quoi c'est de
la désinformation
renault megane le mot de la fin pour
vous on arrive déjà à la fin sur ces
arguments d'alain houpert
beaucoup de français ne veulent pas ces
manifestations vous en tant que médecin
quel est votre état d'esprit vous leur
dites quoi vraiment à ces gens hormis
allez vous faire vacciner pour vous
protéger et protéger les autres ça vous
interpelle poudre même
alors j'allais dire d'abord j'ai entendu
beaucoup de mal heureusement
d'affirmations totalement inexact on va
dire la très grosse majorité des
français soutiennent le pass and i ter
souhaite qu'ils soient maintenus afin
évidemment de garantir une certaine
sécurité sanitaire d'éviter de devoir
recourir en cas de reprise et pique
nique à un confinement alors ce qu'il
faut bien dit c'est qu'aujourd'hui même
si l'intérêt du hassani terre a diminué
là dessus je suis d'accord encore il est
capable de pousser
25000 personnes chaque jour à se faire
vacciner de ce fait il reste toujours
intéressant le deuxième point attention
ça n'est pas le tests virologiques et
protecteur ça c'est une erreur majeure
de raisonnement c'est la vaccination car
même si on rentre dans un lieu avec un
tests virologiques négatif c'est vrai
qu'on n'est probablement pas porteurs du
virus c'est vrai qu'on ne risque pas de
contaminer les eaux par contre on est
tout à fait possible le mans à risque
d'être contaminé donc en aucun cas et
les protecteurs le pass sanitaire
nouveau a pour seul objectif d'inciter à
la vaccination qui est le seul moyen
aujourd'hui qui nous permet d'être
protégé d'une forme grave de la maladie
il est toujours désolant que sa voix
aujourd'hui
cinquante personnes tous les jours sont
admis en réanimation pour y venir et
malheureusement risquer leur vie car ils
n'ont pas souhaité se faire vacciner
alors que le moyen de protection est à
leur portée
c'est vraiment désolant on ne vous
mènera pas d'accord ce soir mais en tout
cas il y avait débat merci à tous les
trois d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france ce soir